scandium is an element which chemists
usually ignore I never you'd scandium in
any of my research its interest lies in
the fact that it's the first of the
so-called transition metals and it is
easily ionized to form salts but it is
less interesting than some of the other
transition metals because it's range of
chemistry is relatively limited compared
to many of the other better known metals
like iron or copper with the result that
because it's been ignored
is now quite fashionable for people to
study the compounds of scandium because
less is known about it and they feel
that there may be something interesting
to discover